laughter tears and quite possibly the
best third act in a Star Wars movie oh
that's what I experienced when I watch
Gareth Edwards rogue one rogue one's
been marketed as a standalone story
within the Star Wars universe but while
it is totally different from the other
movies timing wise it fits super snugly
before the events of the first movie in
the original trilogy and for fans of the
franchise are plenty of cameos and hat
tips to previous installments but what
about the new cast while it's a really
solid ensemble of actors many of whom
really make you care about their
characters and give some standout turns
in the process
unlike Daisy Ridley who was pretty much
an unknown quantity before the force
awakens you've probably already seen
Felicity Jones in movies such as a
theory of everything so it's absolutely
no surprise that as a rebellious jyn
erso jones can play drama and tender
moments to the max but it's fantastic to
also see her so successfully pull out
all the stops when it comes to some
fierce badass action as kate Oso a
reprogrammed Imperial security guard
Alan Tudyk gets to play a character who
has no filter but a great line in back
chat saying whatever pops into his droid
head which results in a multitude of
snark filled laugh-out-loud moments that
show off to dicks perfect comic timing
Donnie Yen brings a wonderful sense of
calm and composure to his blind monk
character cute and yen's incredible
martial arts and athletic abilities are
also on full display in some thrilling
action scenes and I loved the on-screen
chemistry that Yan has with Jiang wen
who plays his soldier friend Bay's mal
bursts both actors really brought out
the beautiful bond between their two
characters to great effect as cargo
pilot Bodhi Riz Ahmed puts in a fine
performance and as rebel intelligence
officer Cassie and Diego Luna gets to
deliver the hell out for particularly
stirring speech well Ben Mendelsohn is
suitably unsettling as the villainous
and ambitious director chronic and
stands out visually thanks to excellent
work in the costume department by
designers David Crossman and Glenn
Dillon in the role of Jin [ __ ] father
Galen Mads Mikkelsen brings out his
character strengths and suffering even
during moments of exposition after
seeing the trailers I've got to admit I
was a bit worried about Forest
Whitaker's liners outlaw rebels saw
Guerrera save the rebellion save the
dream which every time I saw it at the
cinema screamed heroes save the
cheerleader save the world to me
and not in a good way so I was glad to
see that it plays out in a much less
cheesy way in the final movie and it's
actually said in what I felt was a much
more plaintive tone seek context is
everything
Oh in a certain character from the
previous films returns to give you
chills I really liked the way he's
introduced when we see him fully and I
was fine with the amount he appears in
the film too with so many new characters
and locations to introduce rogue one
does take its time to build up a full
head of steam and there is some naughty
plotting and certain inelegant character
shifts which means it's a while before
things get going with the meat of the
movie of course it's been a lot of talk
of long reshoots and just how much of
chris fights his script was reworked by
the Bourne movies Tony Gilroy how many
of those things fed into some of the
film's issues and how many strengths and
it is difficult to say with absolute
certainty the film I'm reviewing here is
obviously the one I saw in front of me
on the big screen and in this rogue one
director Gareth Edwards has made a bold
film that's dark in tone the previous
Star Wars outings that does not shy away
from the complexities and violence of
warfare and that introduces conflicted
characters many of whom work their way
right into my affections and when the
film is at its best we find ourselves in
the middle of a heist and a war movie
with vibes of Saving Private Ryan Meets
The Dirty Dozen via Black Hawk Down and
The Hurt Locker in terms of spectacle
rogue one is dazzling
there are so many heart-stopping and
staring scenes in the movie that brought
tears to my eyes and they build up to an
all-encompassing incredible crescendo
and as the film moves into its final
phase its editors keep nifty cutting
between a variety of characters and
locations ramping up the tension
cinematographer Greg Fraser who's known
for zero-dark says he takes us right
into the middle of the action getting
down and dirty to full gritty effect
making us feel every blast and explosion
as he weaves between obstacles and
enemies just as our heroes do amid the
dust smoke and sand during action scenes
the camera is fluid and often handheld
and apparently director Edwards
regularly operated it himself so kudos
also goes to him for the film's final
look and for also managing to give us
both amazing scale in the film while
still often keeping action grounded on a
more personal level Edwards and
cinematographer Fraser also
make great use of the various locations
where they filmed including the Maldives
for example they really bring out the
contrast between the beautiful beachside
settings and the full-on horror of war
as things are blown to smithereens
beside sapphire waters and perfectly
matching the movie's naturalistic
cinematography is Doug Chang and Neil
Lamont's production design which brings
out the realistically rough edges of the
Star Wars world for some superb stunt
choreography and some truly explosive
scenes props also go to stunt
coordinator Rob inch he worked on the
force awakens and captain Phillips and
two oscar-winning special effects
supervisor Neil kobold whose affection
of seen in Kingsman and Black Hawk Down
and of course it wouldn't be a Star Wars
movie without some spectacular visual
effects and for those we have to thank
Star Wars veteran John Knoll who also
came up with the original idea for rogue
one as well as Moe and Leo who worked on
Ant Man and the Martian there is some
absolutely stunning moments set out in
space as well as on various planets and
moons and so many of the scenes of
destruction which we see from both gods
and worm's-eye views are obviously
properly devastating but also almost
perversely things of extreme beauty the
only place where I say the VFX were
slightly off was with the face of one
particular character I think they did a
good job getting 80% of the way there in
a tough situation but at first I did
find it distracting though later I got
used to it so it didn't spoil the movie
overall for me and of course I've got to
give a shout out to BAFTA winning Neal
Scanlan and his creature effects team
for their work on the movies many new
cool alien life-forms and droids as so
often happens with the Star Wars movies
some of their work just flies by all too
quickly so I can't wait to see it on DVD
so I can take a lingering look over some
of their new creations with his score
for rogue one composer Michael Giacchino
has now completed the full Disney
composing package adding Star Wars to
scores for Disney Animation's utopia
Disney's live-action Tomorrowland
numerous Pixar films and Marvel's Doctor
Strange and what a great job he's done
here - and there's even some lovely
little moments blended in at appropriate
points from John Williams original Star
Wars themes which always makes me feel
like a little kid again
to sum up rogue one is full of both
stunning spectacle and genuinely moving
moments and introduces some engaging new
characters given life
ensemble of accomplished actors though
the film does take a while to rev up and
move through some thorny plot moments
the payoff is so worth it that it's
entirely possible that you leave the
cinema on a super high like I did ro
Guan is the Star Wars prequel I've been
looking for and there's so much the film
gets right that for me it's up there
with the very best Star Wars movies and
its final act is intense
mind blowing cinema and I'm really
looking forward to watching it again so
I'm giving rogue one four and a half out
of 5 flicks now what did you think of
rogue one who are your favorite new
characters and how do you think it
compares to the other Star Wars movies
let me know in the comments below
coming up soon I'll have more rogue one
videos including my Easter Egg Guide to
the movie so be sure to subscribe for
more movie stuff like this and don't
forget to turn on your notifications so
you get my new videos as soon as they're
ready and you can also click or tap here
to check out more of my videos thanks
for watching and see you next time
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers